Marvel has officially confirmed that
they will be once again attending San
Diego comic-con Hall H how's it going
everybody it's Warren and things are
getting really exciting in the Marvel
Universe as Marvel is attending San
Diego comic-con Hall H again in less
than two weeks
on July 20th which is a Saturday we are
going to get 90 minutes of Kevin Feige a
producer and the president of Marvel
Studios talking about the future of the
MCU along with some surprise panelists
as well this will be from 5:15 to 6:45
p.m. again on Saturday July 20th Marvel
has already confirmed that they're going
to be talking about the future of the
MCU which includes movies for phase 4
not to mention all the Disney Plus shows
that we're going to be getting as well
as the Fox characters that Disney now
has the rights to use such as the x-men
the Fantastic Four and many many other
characters so again it's getting really
really exciting because we're finally
going to get a look into what the future
of the MCU looks like so let's go over
all of the phase four movies and shows
that are confirmed and are rumored to be
happening I will be doing constant San
Diego Comic Con updates so if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss any news and also if you
would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield an Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm doing a giveaway at four
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
I'll be choosing three winners so for
the first phase four movie that we know
is confirmed let's start with Black
Widow now technically Marvel has not
officially come out yet and confirmed
that there is a black widow movie
happening however we have leaked set
photos and leaked set videos of Scarlett
Johansson on set of the black widow
movie filming not much is really known
about the plot of Black Widow but we do
know that a new villain is going to be
introduced into the movie and that
villain thanks to some leaked photos
looks to be taskmaster this makes
perfect sense as a villain for the black
widow movie because a black widow is a
master at hand-to-hand combat and one of
taskmasters great abilities is the
ability to be able to mimic his opponent
so we're going to see a lot of a really
great combat in this movie the next
movie for phase 4 that we know is
confirmed that has got a lot of
attention
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and no it
is not going to be called as guardians
of the galaxy James Gunn has confirmed
this with the firing of James Gunn who
directed the first and second guardians
of the galaxy it was unclear on whether
or not guardians 3 was going to happen
but some reports after he got fired came
out and said that guardians 3 was still
going to happen and they were still
going to use the same script that James
Gunn wrote but now James Gunn has been
rehired and we can expect a new
guardians movie sometime in 2021 or 2022
James Gunn will have to finish filming
Suicide Squad 2 before he can begin work
on guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
Suicide Squad 2 comes out in 2021 and
thanks to a recent interview that James
Gunn did we have learned that guardians
3 is going to focus on rocket story and
will finish his story arc and according
to a leak from Roger Wardell on Twitter
Rockets creator is the High Evolutionary
so perhaps he will be one of the
villains and guardians of the galaxy vol
3 along with Adam warlock who everybody
has been waiting to see for a very long
time now another movie that is confirmed
for phase 4 is Doctor Strange 2 as it is
in pre development the Doctor Strange 2
movie is confirmed and it is also
confirmed that Scott Derrickson the
director of the first movie will be back
to direct the second movie and it has
also been reported that see Robert
Cargill the writer of the first Doctor
Strange movie will be back for the
second what's really interesting about
this sequel is that and the end of the
first movie they set up more dough to
become the villain for Doctor Strange 2
however not too long after it came out
the writers said that they would like
Nightmare to be the main villain in
Doctor Strange 2 while at the same time
Scott Derrickson has teased that name
work could be the villain and of course
Doctor Strange no longer has the time
stone so nothing is really keeping
Dormammu away as well
so there is a ton of potential for
Doctor Strange too and the movie is
supposed to start filming next year in
2020 the next movie that is confirmed to
be happening in phase 4 of the MCU is
the Eternals and this is supposed to be
a really really big movie for Marvel the
each pulse has begun casting and
according to reports the cast so far is
absolutely amazing so far it is reported
that Angelina Jolie will be playing the
role of Sayers II and it has also been
reported that Richard Madden will be
playing the role of Icarus and Salma Hey
Kamille Nanjiani and dongsik mal will be
playing major roles in the movie as well
the Eternals were created by the
Celestials and they were tasked by them
to protect the earth a really big thing
about the Eternals is that Thanos is
actually an eternal Thanos his parents
were a Lars and soui son both Eternals
but Thanos was born with the deviant
gene which is why he's all big and
purple but a lot of people are wondering
if we're going to see what Thanos was
like as a child in the Eternals movie we
don't know of a release date yet but
we're hoping to learn more at San Diego
Comic Con in just a few days black
panther 2 is also confirmed to be
happening as they are bringing back
director Ryan Coogler which makes
perfect sense because Black Panther was
a massive success black panther to eric
kill monger has been heavily rumored to
make a return somehow although Kevin
Feige has recently spoken up about it
claiming that this is in no way
confirmed but a lot of people are hoping
that Black Panther 2 is going to
introduce Namor into the MCU Atlantis
and Wakanda have a very long history in
the comics of going to war with one
another and in Avengers in game Akua
mentions that there was an underwater
earthquake just off the coast of Africa
and many people are thinking that this
could be Namor and the Atlanteans
causing these earthquakes
now the Russo brothers have come out and
said that this was not a name or easter
egg but they also told us that Avengers
endgame wasn't going to be the title of
Avengers 4 and Marvel really does their
best not to spoil anything about the
future of the MCU so this very well
could have been a name or reference
another movie that is confirmed to be
coming is shang-chi shang-chi is a
superhero martial artist and not really
much is known about the movie as it is
only in pre-production and has started
casting but fans are super excited to
see him into the MCU now one thing that
has fans really excited about the
possibility of this movie is that the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
has mentioned that the Mandarin the true
Mandarin and the tin rings are going to
enter the MCU now how could this be
possible if we no longer have a Tony
Stark well many people are speculating
that it would make perfect sense to
introduce the Mandarin in shang-chi in
the comics fu-manchu's Shang Chi's
father and there's a lot of talk right
now about fu-manchu's being replaced by
the Mandarin this would definitely be a
very big twist on what we know of
shang-chi and the Mandarin from the
comics but would be an amazing movie to
see then we have some movies that are
expected and rumored to be happening in
phase four but have no official
confirmation yet such as Captain Marvel
- given the massive success that Captain
Marvel had and given the direction that
Marvel and Disney are taking the MCU it
only makes sense that they're going to
do a Captain Marvel - it's inevitably
going to happen we just have no official
confirmation from Marvel yet we are also
expecting a Thor 4
Thor is a fan favorite he's my personal
favorite and given the way Avengers
endgame ended for him it definitely
implies that we're going to be getting
another Thor movie and not to mention
that in Thor Ragnarok they finally found
the direction they want to take Thor and
Taika Waititi and Chris Hemsworth have
both expressed interest and continuing
the story of Thor and the franchise and
then we have a Nova movie which
everybody has been waiting for for a
very long time now and even though it is
not confirmed the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige himself has talked
about they have been trying to introduce
Nova into the MCU for some time now
Kevin Feige has mentioned that
originally Nova was going to be
introduced in guardians of the galaxy
they were then going to put him in
Avengers infinity war in the scene where
fan OHS decimates and are and obtains
the Power Stone they were originally
going to film that scene and Nova was
going to be in it but ultimately they
decided not to and Kevin Feige has said
in recent interviews that out of all of
the characters that are on the board to
be introduced into the MCU Nova is a
priority there have been recent leaks
that say Nova is actually going to be
introduced in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 after guardians 3 he will then get
his own solo film which makes perfect
sense introduce him because nobody knows
who he really is and then give him his
own solo film and since Kevin Feige said
that they were going to introduce him in
guardians 1 it would make sense that
they would try to do it now in guardians
3 and then of course we have a Spider
Man 3 we know that this movie is
confirmed because Tom Holland still has
one more Marvel Disney spider-man film
left and if Disney and Sony continue to
introduce a solo spider-man film every
two years we can expect another one in
2021
but again the movie is confirmed the
release date is not a Fantastic Four
movie has also been heavily rumoured to
be introduced into phase four now this
is just a rumor for now but Kevin Feige
did mention
that out of all of the Fox characters
that Disney and Marvel now have the
Fantastic Four would most likely be
introduced first and if Marvel is
looking for a big bad villain to use in
the future of the MCU Doctor Doom is
definitely an excellent choice and then
of course we have the x-men and other
Fox characters that Kevin Feige said
would probably not be introduced into
the MCU for at least another five years
sadly but now thanks to Disney Plus
along with the movies that are in the
MCU we are now going to have shows that
exist in the MCU as well we have many
shows that are confirmed and a rumored
to be happening on Disney plus one of
which is the Loki series which fans are
super excited about
especially after Avengers end game where
Loki managed to get the tesseract and
escape he no doubt created an alternate
timeline and many people are wondering
what exactly is up to it has been said
that the Loki series will show Loki at
many different points in time and show
how he influenced historical events we
then have a Wanda and vision series that
has been confirmed to be coming out on
Disney Plus and many fans are wondering
how this is going to work considering
the fact that vision is right now dead
now vision was basically built as an
Android so it might not be impossible to
bring him back as an Android and there
was a comic story where vision at one
point in time basically loses all
emotions so we could be looking at
something very similar to that in the
Wanda and vision series in a recent
interview Elizabeth Olsen who plays
Wanda said that there are many stories
from the comic books that haven't been
explored yet she also mentioned that
Wanda and vision will be in the 1950s
and this isn't really too shocking
considering the fact that at the end of
Avengers in game it seemed like
Professor Hulk has pretty much figured
out time travel and then of course we
have a falcon in Winter Soldier series
at the end of Avengers endgame Steve
Rogers handed over his shield and the
mantle of Captain America to Sam so in
the Falcon and Winter Soldier show we
will clearly see Sam as the next Captain
America not really much is known about
the show yet but it has been said to
revolve around the relationship between
the Winter Soldier and Falcon which will
be very interesting to see as Bucky was
born in 1917 and Sam is very much a
modern person so no doubt we'll be
getting some comedy with this new show
we're then going to have a what-if
Marvel series for the fans of the what
if Marvel Comics you're really going to
the show the very first episode is said
to be about Peggy Carter and what if she
was Captain America and there has been a
lot of talk about a Hawkeye series where
he will train Kate Bishop although this
has not been officially confirmed yet so
those are all of the movies and shows
that are confirmed and rumored to be in
phase four be sure to comment with your
thoughts and let me know what you are
most excited to see in phase four also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my Marvel Legends item
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof